once you have a fear that you might be
wrong but you have still the
audaciousness and courage to go forward
you're a lot smarter than the person who
thinks they know there's a quote that
Jefferson said he who knows he knows not
is closer to the truth than he whose
mind is filled with falsehoods and so
when you know that and then with your
character and your determination you go
forward the smartest people I know are
the most humble but the more you learn
the more you realize oh I'm eager to
take in so that's right and I would say
that there are many people in your
audience who can plan for a simple
lifestyle that can be wonderful
sometimes we acquire these needs that
aren't at anywhere near as big as as we
make them out to be do you have a bed to
sleep in do you have food to eat do you
have basic health care okay if you start
to think okay what are my needs that I
really need and I'm okay and how can I
make Provisions for those needs then
once you've got that in your mind you're
free need motivation watch your top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
from one of the best Ray dalio and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
you can go beyond that that you may say
listen oh I can do that for a year or
two years or a month or whatever but you
I think we visualize too much the things
that we're used to one of the good
things about this exercise is that you
can bring it brings you back to basics
you can be brought to Basics and like
I'm saying if you have a bed to sleep in
and you've got food
and so on and you have those Basics and
and good relationships with people who
care about you and basic health care so
if you budget for that and you figure
how do you have it maybe it isn't in the
luxurious
place you're in maybe it's in the
country and so on once you visualize
that and you get that down in your head
and you say oh I can get that
then your stress will disappear because
you as you visualize that in many ways
that's a happy life it doesn't take a
lot to there's stimulation there's
nature there's relationships these
fundamental
wonderful things the most important
things can be obtained and so for many
of you I think if you look at that and
you budget for that I'm seeing a number
of people
who are
um going broke
uh and and I've watched this over many
years
and really it's just the adjustment
process when once they get to that point
where ah you know they have they get
settled
they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's your it's uh icing on the cake
so I want to emphasize you can budget
for that you can look at that find that
scenario find what that looks like so
that you know you've got it down then
you know you're safe once you've got
safe everything beyond that is luxury
rule number two practice meditation
whatever success I've had has come more
from meditation than any other
thing any other influence and you and I
um no because you you're you're a
meditator your wife's a meditator we
meditated in your
um room your meditation room
um we know what it is and I'll explain
what it is
um
um it it I'll first explain what it
gives you and then I'll explain how it
gives you it gives it to you
um it gives you an Equanimity a ability
to almost rise above yourself and to see
things in this
um thoughtful way almost like uh a ninja
in a uh Ninja movie as things are coming
at them everything's sooner seems slower
and you approach it and you can deal
with it in that way and it gives you
um a greater level of creativity and it
does that by uh connecting your
subconscious to your conscious it
achieves that by repeating a mantra so
here's how it works there's a sound that
doesn't have a meaning it's a sound we
could for example it could be something
like oh and mentally you repeat that
over and over again you close your eyes
you get uncomfortable position and you
repeat that and you'll find that your
mind will go to that but then it'll go
to thoughts and you just say oh it's in
thoughts and go back to home and you get
to practice it and what after a while
you'll stay in that meditation that
Mantra and then when you're in that
Mantra
um it will then disappear and then you
go into a Transcendent state in other
words you transcend and you're going
basically into your subconscious and
you're in your subconscious and your
subconscious is really what controls you
more than your conscious you know it's
just you're just not conscious of it
because when you're conscious you know
you think oh well what do I want to do
and so on but your subconscious has such
an influence of the things you've
learned in your earlier years or your
genetics or something and they're not
aware from you and when you go down into
that
um you get relief but you also
um help to make the connection between
your subconscious and your conscious and
so when they're aligned you're aligning
your emotional decisions with your
intellectual decisions so I find uh it's
an instinctual thing for me to do what
do I feel emotionally what do I feel
what do I do think about that
intellectually and then how do I
approach that in that calm way it
doesn't diminish your emotions
um uh it just is you feel them
differently and my my love is as much as
it has ever been my um or more maybe
because I feel it differently so I just
want to emphasize it doesn't take away
your emotions or anything it just puts
them in the perspective as though and
you look above yourself and you see
yourself within the life's Arc you see
the strengths and the weaknesses and how
to deal with them and you navigate
better well number three stop getting
stuck the greatest problem of mankind I
believe wow that's a big statement the
greatest problem of mankind
and it is an exceptional problem at this
moment in time
is people having opinions that they're
stuck on
that
um they won't you know like I have to
have my opinion and that's right and so
on because it prevents them
from
um resolving it from moving forward to
finding the best answer from
compromising and or doing you know so
like everybody's arguing over everything
and and they and you know they're it's
almost like they're killing each other
and and we're in a society
um you know I have another principle
which is when the causes that you're
behind are more important to you and
others than the system the system is in
Jeopardy so do you are you just
literally going to go fight so here we
are as we think will we fight or we have
or will we have protocols for having
thoughtful disagreements and getting
past them rule number four evolve well
I'm 72 years old I know where I am in my
Ark in life
um that the country has been a
tremendous blessing I've lived the
American dream I know what it's like and
I know what my role goal is at 72 years
old and then what is that is to pass
along whatever I have that's of value to
others okay so I think the most
important things that I have are these
principles that I wrote down that work
for uh me I put them out you take them
or leave it uh everybody I'm here I say
what I want you people take it or leave
it and then so my
um my goal is to evolve well and to
contribute to Evolution I think that's
the natural thing so at this particular
Point that's that's what I'm trying to
do also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five find your pull do
you have a poll
okay what's your pull
you know so
um yeah it's all in questions I think
it's all in a journey life isn't a
journey an adventure that's why I'm
trying to say in principles and uh for
success or you can get by the way
principles
um of any of these principles are also
principles in action is an app that's
available on the iStore eyesore and it's
free and it has all of these things in
it but it and so I don't I you know
because we'll we'll separate
um I think people might like that but
you don't have to know your pull and
then along the way you're going to have
your adventure and you're going to learn
and then you go through your phases of
life
and each phase is different like you
talked about your phase you're in the
middle of your phase in life you talked
about your wife and your relationship
with her okay that is a phase of life
and when you go and by putting it in
perspective it's helpful
um in the back of that book uh
principles for Success there's a life
Arc chart
and if you know where you are on that
life Arc
and you know what the next 10 years is
typically like and you know what you the
people you care about are on their life
talks you can almost know what's coming
at you and then you could start to think
about it so it's at that level of
knowing yourself and knowing how these
things happen over and over again that
you can achieve your path don't be
surprised most life is this is the same
things that happen over and over again
you're born you probably have parents to
take take care of you maybe you have one
maybe you have two but somebody does
they teach you you have your first phase
of your life where you're dependent on
them and you're learning then you come
out to your second phase of your life
and then you're working and others are
dependent on you and then you have that
so these things happen over and over
again and and you just have to know that
path and know how to approach it rule
number six Venture into the jungle have
you
celebrate and embrace successes in your
life too we just spoke about failure I'm
intrigued to know how someone like
yourself deals with success
well I think my Approach my thinking
about success has evolved over a period
of time I I thought about success I
today think about success differently uh
it's like um the way I thought about it
originally when I uh you know you have
this failure uh I thought that it's like
there's a jungle out there
um I want to have the great greatest
life possible but in order to be
successful I can I have to cross this
dangerous jungle now I could stay on the
one side of the Jungle and have a a
boring safe life but
um unless I deal with the risks
um risks in return go together and it's
like going into this jungle so what
would I choose would I choose to go into
the jungle and cross the jungle and have
the greatest life possible but I might
get bad things might happen and then I
started to think when I went into that
jungle I of course I had to cross the
jungle but I started to realize how to
cross the jungle most importantly with
people who could see things differently
than I could on the mission with me and
so that and we would protect each other
in that jungle and that's what it was
like so life is a lot like that who are
you in the jungle with and they might
see things differently from you and then
you protect each other and you go
through and the thing that I discovered
was that as I had these successes and
failures and much more successes than
failures I began to realize that I
didn't care as much about the success as
I cared about the journey okay in other
words I didn't want to get out of the
Jungle I didn't want to get to the other
side because it might be like I don't
know climbing mountains or doing
whatever you realize there's a new Peak
and there's a new level of success and
they won't keep you happy okay you you
don't sit there you want to go on yes
and and it is the ups and downs of that
journey and the striving into becoming
better that becomes the new definition
of success and so I started to see my
life in this life Arc way with my
preferences changing because your
preference is naturally change as one
has kids and as they as they start to
think I mean everybody that you're
dealing with is going through into life
Arc if you think about who are the
people you love
what is your relationship with your
parents what are your relationships you
have children who with they will have a
life Arc and as you go through that life
Arc and you see those things changing
then you start to realize that operating
consistent with that life Arc is and on
that journey to evolve well is what
success is it's not yes the money it's
like money loses its marginal utility
very quickly right if you studies of
Happiness
um there's a Harvard Professor many
professors I suppose and they tell you
the same thing in terms of studying
happiness around the world there's very
little correlation between how much
money you have in the level of Happiness
past the basics of assistance level the
element that there's the highest
correlation with is an element of
community who you're with so it's this
meaningful work are you on a mission and
meaningful relationships through a life
Arc that evolves so that's it might be
definition of success is more like
evolving well and contributing to
Evolution rule number seven get
inspiration I admire
um so many people
um I think the one of the problems we
have today is we don't have Heroes
we don't have role models and heroes
because so many people are interested in
tearing down people
I don't know how we got to that but it's
true I think the the internet helped
helped in social media helped we need
more there are so many great people role
models who could be role models and I'm
and I think um
of just so many in my lifetime that I've
seen rule number eight seek good advice
let me just
on the thing yes it's the looping and
learning from mistakes
but it it another part of it
is the realization that you don't have
to make your decisions in your own head
okay now when you start to realize that
you know what you're good at and what
you're bad at that a power comes to you
when you start to know uh okay who's the
best person to give me the advice or
who's the best person to lead me through
this or when you start to know that you
can go beyond what you think and your
opinionatedness so that you can
triangulate I call it triangulate with
others so that you find three people who
are really
capable of giving you good advice who
will argue with each other and argue
with you so you can see all sides of it
and you work yourself through so it's
not just your eyes looking for the path
but it's other people's eyes looking
with the path with you knowing that
you're going to have uh successes and
failures but that power of that
collective learning and triangulate well
with humbleness is a great power as you
go through that cycle rule number nine
practice radical truthfulness I
mentioned that you believe in the
socratic dialogue and also sort of
radical transparency
which is the stress testing of
yeah the culture of Bridgewater that I
learned from these experiences is I'll
say it in one sentence
an idea meritocracy in which the goals
are meaningful work and meaningful
relationships
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency so I want the best ideas to
win out that's the idea of meritocracy
wherever they come from
I believe in meaningful work and
meaningful relationships reinforcing
each other that if they're the greatest
reward and if you have that together
um then you're going to be more
successful if you're on a mission that's
the work you're on then you're on a
mission together and you have that tight
relationship that's a great power but
it's through that Mutual generosity and
Gary and that you have to do that
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency radical truthfulness I mean
um you first of all you've got to find
out what's true it's the foundation of
anything so you have to be able to talk
about anything uh and get to truth truth
might be what your weaknesses are as
well as what your successes are so it
has that truthfulness and that idea
meritocracy to figure it out and do it
together those are very powerful things
yes I learned that and rule number ten
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is help others the issues
that we're dealing with like one of the
things that we're trying to do
um my wife
does this six days a week is I'm various
ways try to get
um uh programs and things that get high
school kids and eighth and Ninth Grade
to get them through uh high school and
into work
um B in the state of Connecticut okay
um and um give you a statistic the state
of Connecticut has uh is one of the
richest States on average but has a big
wealth Gap
um 22 percent of the high school
students are either disengaged or
disconnected disengage means the
absentee rate is greater than 25 in
their failing classes and disconnected
means that they don't know where they
are because they've dropped out of
school in other words more than one in
five students High School is failing and
so
um and they're failing High School and
the budget issues are a problem we I
live in Greenwich Connecticut and it's a
rich town the average
um per student for the for public high
school twenty four thousand dollars
it'll go up the hill and 15 minutes away
and
um it's Bridgeport Connecticut it's a
poor town and it's fourteen thousand
dollars a student they need more money
because there's hunger there's
um there's bads conditions they need
more money than Greenwich Connecticut
and yet they're getting significantly
less so what's the natural consequence
of that the parents who are raised under
these very impossible that kids become
parents and they're raised under these
circumstances and what is their
community and what is their income their
Community is the gangs that because
that's their Community that's the one
they can relate to that and everybody
needs a community and what are their
income it's crime
um in one form or another and there are
gone gangs and shootings all the time
and we're in a situation where of course
that creates not only the crime costs
but it also creates incor high
incarceration costs because state pays
600 million dollars a year for
incarceration
so you create a cycle in order to break
that cycle you need everything from
early childhood education all the way
through that yeah and and that has to
make an improvement yeah and that's why
I say you might even need um reforms to
the Constitution because the State
education is a state issue
and in the states they tend to make it a
tax District issue and so there's no way
that you're going to get that now the
cost of that bad education is immense
for the country because not only is is
it unfair but also you don't know where
the talent is going to come from
throughout history you find that the
most talented people can come from
anywhere and and there's only basic
things you need to have what I had when
I was growing up I was very lucky I had
two parents who cared for me that were
good guidance I went to a public school
and I came out to a a country of equal
opportunity so I could work hard and
that was it
um and we need to I think in one way or
another
um establish that there's a bottom that
nobody can go below and to realize that
those are good Investments the same is
true for infrastructure there's
um no inadequate infrastructure my
gender generation has given the Next
Generation a lot of debt a broken down
education system and a broken down
infrastructure so that's going to
require a lot so my general reaction is
philanthropy is woefully inadequate
to give the knowledge uh teach a man how
to fish is better than to give him a
fish I mean I think you can give them
both you can give education and you can
sure but ability the the capacity to be
productive because you know if I can
give you the capacity to go out in the
world it's like go into a jungle I give
you a knife and can you live in the
jungle okay if I give you that capacity
that's the best thing I can give you
that's why I wrote the book and you know
pass it along I wrote those principles
over years and I wrote them down and
that's what I want to pass along that's
the most important thing yeah but but if
you but if you've got money you can help
people a lot in a lot of different ways
which is thrilling what would you say
then are the three greatest skills that
people that aren't financially abundant
or that are struggling financially
should learn to master in order to be in
a better position financially three
skills what would you say they should
learn well as I said before I remember
watching the movie I was young David
Copperfield with WC Fields and he speaks
to David Copperfield and he says he said
something like and I'll put it in dollar
terms you're at a hundred dollars and
you spend 105 dollars
that's misery
if you earn a hundred dollars and you
spend ninety five dollars you'll have a
good life
I mean it wasn't exactly like that but
it was but but basically
I know so many people who don't earn
much but are there because if you start
to think about what it is that it costs
you to live in terms of let's say the
basics you know uh give me a bit to
sleep and give me the food let me be
educated and so on so forth I think most
people can get themselves in a position
where you know they're not positive so
if you can be net positive and you could
do that that you know that's
number one
uh you know as I carry that so that's
you know that's number one then I guess
it was the list that we went to you know
the second is you know what do you do
next
in terms of what do you need what do you
invest in you know and then and then you
know going Beyond it and then there
avoid the following mistake the most
common mistake of investing thinking
that the investment that did good
is a good investment
people rather more expensive
the things that quite often
those markets that did really really
well became more more expensive and
everybody smart money is all the time
compete comparing them and competing
so what happens is
um the naive money
buys the thing that was hot or is hot
the thing that has been terrible which
might be the thing that's beaten down so
I would say also an important element
okay so here's another one that's really
important diversify
um so don't put all your eggs in one
basket right because what I learned
about this
is that first of all all Investments
uh compete and it's not easy to sell
tell whether one investment's better
than the other because if people could
do that life would be easy and everybody
make a ton of money
um so and this is as competitive game
that's very difficult to compete in so
it's very difficult to say which one's
better or worse you could take experts
and you could and do all sorts of tests
and you'll find out that they can pick
that and you can't tell whether the
worst ones are going to be better so
because of that you understand that um
even picking the best ones is difficult
and particularly if you're naive like we
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
each year on Research to try to give us
an edge okay now you've got to compete
with us so uh competing in the markets
is more difficult than competing in the
Olympics you wouldn't think I'm going to
compete in the Olympics but there are
more people who try harder
in order to do that so it's a zero-sum
game so but diversification
that they're different uh will reduce
your risk without reducing your return
yeah so if you know how to diversify
well
so
um that's critical so I would say again
uh get get your savings right and the
reasons I say I would say
um have great humility about what you
what you don't know don't buy the thing
that was hot just because you think it's
hot
um and then know how to diversify well
that those would be the most important
things I could convey your company
anticipated the financial crisis managed
your clients funds through that period
make the argument that your culture
actually has something to do with that
result well
first of all I think that
well I'll tell you what the moment was
like you do our calculations and
we have a view that's very different
than the rest of the world's View at
that time
so the independent thinking
we had among ourselves different people
who had different views and the ability
to work ourselves through those
um was essential for us to being able to
stand upside from the crowd so I needed
to have the independent thinking and we
needed to work it through and then even
at that time we had to have
um the fear of being wrong
because you can never be confident that
you're right in the markets and so to
place the bet but to place the bet in a
defensive way and to work out together
um the engineering what what I believe
is that everything happens over and over
again
through history
World operates like a machine it happens
over and over again and that if you can
sort of go above yourself in your
circumstances and look down at yourself
within your circumstances within a
historical perspective and then have
agreed upon principles
you know principles are how to handle
things that happen over and over again
by having that it's helpful and ours are
just oriented around this idea
meritocracy so it allowed us to have an
independent point of view while being
not a hundred percent certain and you
know to be defensive and it allowed us
to play that well there were three
things that happened in my lifetime that
are happening now that didn't happen in
my lifetime before and that I needed to
study and that was an enormous amount of
creation of debt and the monetization of
that in a financial piece
the second is the internal conflict
populism of the right and the left
um that and with wealth gaps and so on
that I like to measure things that you'd
have to go back to 1900 to see those
degrees of conflict which I think are a
threat to our system and a democracy and
could produce a civil war type of
situation
and third the rise of a great power to
challenge an existing great power in the
existing World Order now those three
things in their degrees individually but
also collectively last time they
happened was 1930 to 45 period And so
when I what I needed to do was to
understand those patterns and those
things and I took it into it and so what
I'm hoping to show is simply the
mechanics of it in a lot of and then
explain why it appears that we are in an
important juncture now what we do with
that juncture so yes it's measured and
and there are the United States is in
relative to to decline in by measures
which are measured and China has been
rising and that's an issue but that
doesn't create necessarily A Destiny it
creates a situation which I hope we can
we'll go through that can you go to what
you're like can you go to your mistake
can you go to your weaknesses
right can you go to other people's
mistakes and weaknesses some people
because of an ego barrier can't do that
and so if they don't recognize their own
mistakes their own weaknesses or others
mistakes and weaknesses what the root
cause me being what they're like because
of ego barriers if they can't go there
they're going to repeat those mistakes
they're going to have them over and over
again
so it's the process essentially of
saying at that stage what am I like
everybody has strengths and everybody
has weaknesses the weaknesses are the
other side of the strengths so let's say
if you're you know a right brain
creative person you may not be reliable
because just the way you think
necessitates you to think a certain way
that means you can't think in another
way that means you're going to keep
bumping into that thing that's standing
in your way but unless you can Embrace
I'm not reliable
all right and deal with it you won't get
around it it's still going to continue
to be a barrier right so the diagnosis
to the root cause is is important so
then
if you diagnose it then you have to
design what are you going to do about it
that works
so
um let's say you are very creative but
not reliable okay you have to find the
means of it first of all embracing that
and then saying
um if I'm not reliable what do I do it
do I work with a reliable person do I
learn reliability do I have some
compensating mechanism because I can't
let that lack of reliability stand in
the way my goal as long as I keep doing
that I'm going to keep running into
problems so you have to design what you
do about the problems and then when
you're designing what you do about the
problems
then you have to follow it through so
you have to
follow through or or do the thing you
designed
um and and and the doing the thing you
um requires self-discipline and so on so
people have to do those things in order
to be successful right they have to know
what their goals are they they have they
will encounter their problems they have
to diagnose those problems down to the
root cause the real root cause they have
to design ways to get around them and
then they have to have the
self-discipline to follow that and it's
a continuous iterative process so that
that's what we keep doing right so
you're going in that direction I would
say that all of the Shapers are doing
that they're doing that
they're doing that well right so they
don't mind the problems they don't mind
that I want to distinguish there's big
differences in Opportunities yes so
let's say supposing you have two people
of comparable opportunities yes and then
they were going to do that okay
the marshmallow test yeah as you as as
you know apparently is you take a kid
and you say okay uh you can have one
marshmallow now or you could have two
marshmallows in 15 minutes if you don't
eat the first one yeah if you don't eat
the first one right yep okay once you
start to realize
that deferred gratification
is going to make you better and so on
and you start to count count and you say
like something like how many
days weeks months or years can I live
if I don't have money come in and you
start to focus in on that
that's the first step okay like the
marshmallow test okay so I want to save
you got to start there then if you do
that
you're necessarily going to go save in
what
and then you'll start to get exposure
to
how these things are different
okay then you start to care I can have
one of these and one of those and you
start to experience
and then you start to learn
and basically that's what makes the
difference you have no idea how you all
see things differently
that there's a thinking Spectrum some
people are creative and not reliable
some people are reliable not creative
and as you start to give people uh
personality tests like Myers-Briggs or
the big five or different personality
tests you start to learn how people see
things differently and then when you see
them differently and you and that screen
pops up wherever rather than just seeing
how you see it you go above that and
you're seeing that everybody is seeing
things differently it changes how you
see things because it starts to make you
think
um how do I know I'm not the wrong one
in other words as you go above it and
you look down on all those different
ways of seeing you start to think
how do I know I'm not the wrong one and
how do I collectively see and you see in
a color range it's like seeing in a
different color range or going from two
Dimensions to three dimensions all of a
sudden you see the full spectrum of
seeing things and then you go to the
higher level we have systems that go
through the computers that go the higher
level that say then how do we weigh all
those ways of seeing to make the best
decisions
so not so you don't get so attached to
your opinions I think the greatest
tragedy of mankind is people holding on
to wrong opinions that could so easily
be rectified and that's doing them hard
because they're making wrong decisions
so how do you collectively do that well
the answer is by everybody seeing
everything and seeing how others see
they begin to gain those perspectives
they also get to get an appreciation for
the other way of seeing it used to be
that everybody would drive each other
crazy you you your brain works in one
way my brain works in another maybe I
see big picture you see detail right
maybe I'm creativity you're reliable we
drive each other crazy when you start to
realize that people are actually seeing
in those ways and that's a valid way of
seeing and that I need you and you need
me and how to put together the team as
you're asking about it gives you the
evidence base it's okay to be different
in 1968 The Beatles went to India and
they meditated and then I I heard about
it and then in 1969 in New York you
could
you can bring some flowers and you could
be that and you could learn how to
meditate and and wow I recommend it's
the best thing gift I can do it every
day or every almost every almost yeah I
try to do it every day I try to do it
about twice a day and if I could take a
second to describe it
um what it is
is it frees your mind of thought and it
takes you from a conscious State into
your subconscious and your subconscious
is where creativity comes from and
Equanimity and and all of that like if
you're calm and great ideas come to you
and when you have that Equanimity then
you as you're approaching everything
things are just the way they are and you
have to deal with them and it's a little
like being you know in the ninja movies
it's a little bit like being the ninja
and everything seems slower you can
handle it better and so and you align
your subconscious which is where the
motions and also Inspirations come from
with your conscious mind and when
they're aligned and you have that
Equanimity it's a great thing if I'm
making a decision
um that that after I make the decision
usually or right at the time if I pause
and reflect and I write my principle
down in other words principle is sort of
a recipe what would I use to how would I
make that decision and what are the
criteria around it I find that I make it
much more clear it becomes clearer and
it applies to the next thing that comes
along it'll be that way because
everything happens over and over and
over again and I think people make the
mistake of looking at just the one like
it's the first one they have I don't
know they have the first problem of this
sort of the first child or whatever it
is and this has been happening plenty of
times and so if you have the principles
I found that that helped me think more
clearly about it and it helped me
communicate better like why and so over
the years over the last 30 years or so
that's what I I've done I did it
originally to communicate very well with
people I work with you know I set up my
company and and it was very important to
have good communication and then we
could debate the principles and so
that's the process I urge people to do
that there are many excellent decision
makers
um and I just wish that they wrote down
their principles when this set so for
example we'll be talking about Henry
Kissinger and his new book is going to
come out with a book on leadership
um and don't just describe the leaders
describe then what about them were the
Essential Elements to make a good leader
under what circumstances and so if we
think about that when then also then you
begin to think in a principled way and
then when you start to think in a
principal way life becomes it's so much
easier to make decisions and it's so
much less confusing because it's like
coming up on a species and you say okay
well what species is it not just another
it's a thing no what species is it and
how do I deal with that species
effectively and and so that's what that
is and so I encourage people to write it
down I wish anybody who's successful
wrote down their principles or their
recipes for making those types of
decisions I think every place has to
have a culture right
and culture is the values what what
values are living out and and so for
example this the number one value is
it has to make sense to you we have to
talk about it we have to work it through
in a non-egotistical kind of way
and so it's an unusual place and it's an
unusual culture
are you offended when people sometimes
label it a cult
I think that I think a cult when I think
of a cult it means believe this
and we're it's the opposite you're taken
from on high in other words a cult mean
yeah
somebody's telling you believe this
because I said to follow it because I
have a superior it's exactly the
opposite of that right the number one
principle is don't believe anything
think for yourself and now let's go
through a process of what is true
together
but we can't stop that with ego we can't
let that barrier stand in our way so
we're going to live in a culture in
which we can do that okay now that's the
opposite of okay it's it's a belief
system in other words I'll ask you do
you believe that we should operate this
way with each other
okay if you want to call that a cult I
think it's the opposite of a cult it
means think
right speak up don't hide it don't talk
behind people's backs it's talking
behind people and you always make a
point that you know what you don't know
and that's equally valuable more
valuable
I want to say that
um
so this is the whole philosophy
I I so know that I can be wrong and look
we all should recognize that we can be
wrong
and if we recognize that we're wrong and
we worry about being wrong then what we
should do is have a thoughtful dialogue
then you start your own company right
yeah and when incredibly well at the
beginning
1975. it was me a guy played rugby with
in my two bedroom apartment okay and uh
everything went well until it didn't go
well that's right and did you then have
to go borrow money from your father yeah
so yes so what happened was you know
um it was a very small company just uh
you know a handful of people and I love
to trade the markets and we did for
institutions and then he
um and then in
1979 80 81 I calculated that uh foreign
that the American Banks had lent more
money to foreign countries than the
countries were going to get paid back
and um and I had its controversial world
view that the world you know is going to
be a big debt crisis and Mexico
defaulted in 1982 so very interesting
1982.
and um when they defaulted I got a lot
of attention and I thought we were going
to have a terrible economic set of
circumstances and I could not have been
more wrong it was exactly the opposite
in August when they defaulted another
country started to default it was the
exact bottom in the stock market and so
I had to let off everybody and I was
down to me and I
um you know I said to myself well am I
going to have to put on a tie and go
drop take the train in and go to Wall
Street and so on I couldn't bring myself
to do that
um and I I was so broke that I had to
borrow four thousand dollars for my dad
to uh pay the bills and this was the
best thing that ever happened to me I
mean painful but it was one of the best
things that ever happened to me because
it gave me the humility I needed to
balance with my audacity and then I I
needed to understand how can I have the
upside without having the downside you
know how and then I understood the
portfolio construction and risk
management and so on so forth so that
was my bottom and that punch in the face
that experience was one of the best
things that happened did you pay your
father back in some point the four
thousand dollars plus he didn't want
equity in Bridgewater
he didn't ask me no I think he he was
smarter than that I think it's very
important to know what people are like
yet most organizations don't want to go
there
by knowing what people are like and
having them part of the process of
knowing what they're like there's better
understanding better communication and
also of course you can make better teams
because there nobody has all that's
needed to be successful
um you know we need each other to play
different roles and the ability to do
that by knowing what people alike is
enhanced know your goals
um know what you're going after
you could have almost anything you want
but you can't have everything you want
and so you have to prioritize and you
move in that direction
on the way to your goals you're going to
encounter your problems and your
obstacles
so identifying now step two is
understanding your problems and your
obstacles identify them step three is to
diagnose them to get at the root cause
of the problem
and that could be many root causes but
it could also be your weaknesses or
weaknesses of others but you have to be
objective about them once you diagnose
them then you go to step four which is
to design a way to get around them
uh and then after you have that design
you implement that design so you have to
follow through and do it and you do that
and and that will then produce its new
results which should be better results I
have I call this kind of the looping
process it's the evolutionary looping
process and
um you do you just keep doing that and
you learn over a period of time and you
move in the direction that you want
firstly can you tell us are you
authentically satisfied and fulfilled do
you have an experience in life of being
successful I don't think that success is
like a lot of people uh believe it is
and for any really successful person I
think that um everybody's always
struggling and what happens is you know
you just struggle at a higher level it's
like learning how to ski or play some
Sport and you're just kind of doing this
higher thing but it doesn't feel like
that if it just feels like I'm
struggling and I think it's um
and and it's a good feeling I I the way
I think of it is um
I've always thought that it's like in
order to be successful in life you have
to cross a jungle
or you could stay on the other side of
the Jungle and not cross the jungle but
if you choose to cross the Jungle the
jungle has all sorts of
things that can do your harm and bite
you and everything along those lines and
so the West best way to do that is to go
into that with people who can see things
differently and watch themselves and
struggle to make it to the other side
and then what I've discovered along the
way is that it's always a struggle and I
enjoy being in the jungle
I don't want to get to the underside I
don't want to get out so that's what it
feels like to me it's the mixture of the
elements that matter right if you have a
tremendous tenacity but you're you're
studying you're learning you're trying
to memorize and remember everything that
you're being taught and you're really
trying hard you could have great
tenacity you need the making sense of
something you need to embrace reality
you need these other dimensions right so
I think the things that we started to
talk about just before the you know the
things that these people have a need for
is is first they need to most
fundamentally make sense of things which
is a very different kind of learning
process it's a very internalized
learning process it's not a memory based
process so none of these people unlike
the population whole none of these
people have a desire to follow
instructions for most people you you you
go to school they tell you what class to
go to
um they what classes to take this goes
all the way through University they they
do this do this to this and then you go
into the class and they say learn this
and this is the information and it's
largely a memory based instructional
based process this is not what these
people do right this is not so the path
what they what they have is a strong
strong desire to understand and make
sense of reality how does reality work
every time I made a mistake they became
painful mistakes but with time I
realized that reflecting on those
mistakes would give me gems
um what I would do is I'd say why did I
make that mistake and I would learn from
that mistake and I'd write down a rule
so what was helpful for me is I put that
rule principles these principles I wrote
These principles down those principles
that I wrote down I then put into
algorithms in other words equations and
what I learned by being able to do that
is by if I took my decision criteria
those principles and then I tested them
back through time I gained a perspective
that was fantastic I could test them in
back a hundred years I could test them
in different countries and I would learn
how those rules work and I put by
putting all those rules together and
then how having these algorithms the
computer could replicate my thinking but
it could actually think better than I
could because it what it would do is it
would take it it could process more
information it could process it faster
and it could process it less emotionally
so it was like having a GPS that was
next to me while I was also making my
decisions like you're driving in a car
and you have both operating and to have
that next to me was um you know
invaluable it would learn I would learn
and together we built that I think the
key is to think of reality as
you're given reality is reality and
think of it as working like a machine
they're a cause effect relationships
that make the realities around you okay
now if you go above yourself and you
look at that how does that machine work
and then how do I interact with that
machine to get what I want and you do
that with an Equanimity meditation also
helped me a lot yes I learned to
meditate uh very in many years ago and
if you if you have Equanimity and you
look at it above and you look at with
curiosity and you say oh I must not be
interacting well with at my reality and
how do I change it and how does it work
it's a very powerful way of approaching
life so the big shift in terms of going
to
um the notion of what do I do with my
money let's say you have a lot of
liquidity and you're looking the world
has lots of liquidity today the world
has lots of liquidity the question is
what are its choices
and what do those choices look like and
then you put your money so you produce a
lot of money around a lot of liquidity
and then say do you stop buying U.S
bonds uh when you have or do you stop
buying
Japanese bonds uh when you have
uh no interest rate on a currency risk
um and and so what when do you stop
buying well it's when you have
confidence in some ultimately when it's
driven to something else at some point
you get a move toward inflation if
there's a move toward like I want to
hold inflation assets then you come into
problems until you don't have that move
to move toward inflation assets you have
a capacity for a lot of the buying there
and it and so the timing that's that oh
the people who feel like they're I'm
good I've got it
won't learn if you've got it you won't
learn
right so so you have to get rid of this
ego barrier I've got it thing I think
first of all one has to know their
nature
um
you might have to discover it but your
nature means do you have a sense of
adventure do you seek security are you
an extrovert and introvert those types
of things so personal Discovery is
important
um I think that uh who you're with
and where you are is more important than
what you do because in the early phase
of that second phase it's total
Discovery so it's experimentation you
know you went to India for three years
right yes and and that but if you have
that sense of adventure to let go you
can discover that's your opportunity but
discover yourself as well as to discover
what the choices are like and then as
you move later into that you'll feel the
pulls
um and to feel never trapped we were
talking just before we began that so
many people say
um you know I can't be that way because
I my job won't allow it which is a silly
concept because you have the freedom of
those choices even in when you have
constraining uh situations so I think uh
that's the life Arc
enjoy this wide open choice you can be
anywhere in the world you can do almost
anything let go experiment and then move
on
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Grant Cardone
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you've got a
thousand dollars I would like just keep
investing yourself until you got another
thousand and then invest in yourself you
should start making money faster you
know there's things I bought that I
didn't get a return on right away but I
didn't quit investing in a course or a
workshop